my favorite kind of guests are people
who do something I would never do in a
million years and you have done that I
know that you are a professional pilot
and you are a professional high divers
scale envision skydiver okay and you
guys came up with this idea first of all
did you invent this suit that you're
wearing
yes exactly all right the idea to come
out of the box in an airplane you are in
the books right and I wanted to be
completely in the air yes it's good to
be in the plane no don't you think what
I never think that whenever I'm in the
plane I think it's good in the plane
yeah but the you are like you know
submarine in water yeah I prefer to swim
yeah well let's take a look at that's
crazy
I'd stay on the sub as well here is what
this is a scale model of what it is that
you guys are wearing is that correct yes
again and I want to make sure that
people see this and yes your legs don't
quite look like this look at these legs
they're bending the wrong way
that's after countless injuries tell us
this is the suit this is insane looking
you guys this these are jet engines yes
model jet engines just mounted on a wing
that gives us lift and these four
engines are pushing us in the air up to
200 miles per hour
oh my god okay 200 miles per hour all
right I have a lot of questions first of
all you flew next to the largest
commercial airliner in the world are you
at all worried about getting sucked into
the engine I mean no I mean for sure the
engine yeah I wish you just said no then
left it at that
another dent in the other but we took
some margin we are the safety is number
one thought so we took sorry don't say
that don't say safety
I hate it when guys like you say yes I
strap jet engines to my back and jump
out of a plane but safety comes first
without that can't be true
now if she's great you know it's like an
extension of our body and we can fly in
the air like a breath you know it's like
the the dream of most of us you know to
fly to Kabul on now do you not my dream
again I have very different dreams more
sexual in nature but they also involve
this suits are good so I'm curious will
this ever be something that's
commercially available do you think that
will ever be flying instead of sitting
in traffic here in Los Angeles on the
405 freeway will we all be flying these
one day but it's not Beth Modell but it
comes for sure
you think this is gonna come for sure as
a reality for people everywhere yes okay
yeah all right
I pray that I don't live to see that day
okay I see people make terrible
decisions in the Prius ahead of me going
20 miles an hour watching those same
people in this suit is frightening to me
what is the best body type for flying
one of these contraptions you me are you
serious yeah skinny a good the air
surface it's perfect
what about the fact that I have very
long ungainly limbs wouldn't that I
seriously have very long
disproportionate legs and arms that flap
wildly when I do anything you will have
just to pay attention to don't put your
hand at the end of the exhaust because
it's a thousand degrees so it's a
two-bit hot
I'll remember that yes or I'll hold an
uncooked chicken in my hand hey thanks
for watching please subscribe to my
youtube channel so they will stop making
me shoot these videos please